Speaking of psychology is taking a short winter break, so we're revisiting one of our favorite episodes from the past year. In March, we talked to Pamela Dalton from the Manel Chemical Sciences Center about how scientists are gaining a deeper understanding of human's sophisticated sense of smell and learning more about how intertwined it is with our memories, emotions, and mental and physical health. We also talked about how the COVID-19 pandemic has added new urgency to this research. I hope you enjoy this episode from our archives. Speaking of psychology, we'll be back in January with new weekly episodes. Thank you for listening. Smell has been called our most underappreciated sense. When people think about it, if they think about it at all, many consider it an evolutionary relic, something that is important for animals but not for us humans. We tend to think we aren't
Speaking of psychology is taking a short winter break, so we're revisiting one of our favorite episodes from the past year. In March, we talked to Pamela Dalton from the Manel Chemical Sciences Center about how scientists are gaining a deeper understanding of human's sophisticated sense of smell and learning more about how intertwined it is with our memories, emotions, and mental and physical health. We also talked about how the COVID-19 pandemic has added new urgency to this research. I hope you enjoy this episode from our archives. Speaking of psychology, we'll be back in January with new weekly episodes. Thank you for listening. Smell has been called our most underappreciated sense. When people think about it, if they think about it at all, many consider it an evolutionary relic, something that is important for animals but not for us humans. We tend to think we aren't|||《Speaking of psychology》正在进行短暂的寒假休息，所以我们重温了过去一年中最喜欢的节目之一。在三月份，我们采访了莫内尔化学感官中心的帕梅拉·道尔顿，探讨了科学家们如何深入了解人类高度复杂的嗅觉，并进一步了解嗅觉与我们的记忆、情感以及身心健康之间千丝万缕的联系。我们还探讨了 COVID-19 大流行如何为这项研究增添了新的紧迫性。希望大家喜欢我们档案库里的这一期节目。《Speaking of psychology》将于一月份携每周新节目回归。感谢您的收听。嗅觉被称为我们最被低估的感官。当人们想到它时——如果他们会去想的话——许多人认为它是进化的遗留物，对动物很重要，但对我们人类却不然。我们往往认为自己甚至
even that good at detecting smells, certainly not as good as our dogs, for instance. About 10 years ago, a The international poll found that more than half of young people said they'd be willing to give up their sense of smell before they'd give up their laptop or cell phone. But in recent years, scientists have begun to learn more about this overlooked sense and how to gain a new understanding of how sophisticated human sense of smell really is, and how it is intertwined with our mental and physical health. Now the COVID-19 pandemic is giving this research new urgency because one common side effect of the virus, even among people with otherwise mild cases, is the loss of or changes in the sense of smell. Some people recover their sense quickly, but for others,
even that good at detecting smells, certainly not as good as our dogs, for instance. About 10 years ago, a The international poll found that more than half of young people said they'd be willing to give up their sense of smell before they'd give up their laptop or cell phone. But in recent years, scientists have begun to learn more about this overlooked sense and how to gain a new understanding of how sophisticated human sense of smell really is, and how it is intertwined with our mental and physical health. Now the COVID-19 pandemic is giving this research new urgency because one common side effect of the virus, even among people with otherwise mild cases, is the loss of or changes in the sense of smell. Some people recover their sense quickly, but for others,|||连辨别气味都不那么在行，当然远不如我们的狗。大约 10 年前，一项国际民意调查发现，超过一半的年轻人表示，他们宁愿放弃嗅觉，也不愿放弃笔记本电脑或手机。但近年来，科学家们开始更多地了解这种被忽视的感官，并重新认识到人类的嗅觉到底有多复杂，以及它与我们的身心健康是如何交织在一起的。现在，COVID-19 大流行赋予了这项研究新的紧迫性，因为该病毒的一个常见副作用——即使在病情较轻的人群中——也是嗅觉丧失或改变。有些人很快就能恢复嗅觉，但对其他人来说，
the changes seem to be long-lasting or perhaps even permanent. Why is this happening? And what are the consequences for those who are affected? More broadly, how important is our sense of smell? What are the connections between smell and our emotions? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Pamela Dalton, an experimental psychologist at the Monel Chemical Senses Center in Philadelphia, an independent nonprofit research institute dedicated to studying the senses of taste and smell. Dr. Dalton's research focuses on how our emotions and cognitive processes affect the way that we experience smell,
the changes seem to be long-lasting or perhaps even permanent. Why is this happening? And what are the consequences for those who are affected? More broadly, how important is our sense of smell? What are the connections between smell and our emotions? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Pamela Dalton, an experimental psychologist at the Monel Chemical Senses Center in Philadelphia, an independent nonprofit research institute dedicated to studying the senses of taste and smell. Dr. Dalton's research focuses on how our emotions and cognitive processes affect the way that we experience smell,|||这些改变似乎是长期的，甚至可能是永久性的。为什么会这样？对受影响的人来说会有什么后果？更广泛地说，我们的嗅觉有多重要？嗅觉与我们的情绪之间有什么联系？欢迎收听《Speaking of psychology》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是帕梅拉·道尔顿博士，她是费城莫内尔化学感官中心（一个致力于研究味觉和嗅觉的独立非营利研究机构）的实验心理学家。道尔顿博士的研究重点是我们的情绪和认知过程如何影响我们体验嗅觉的方式，
and how smell affects our emotions and our memories. She's been called a smell ebriety, especially because of her work to identify the worst smell in the world, which we will talk about. How could we not? She's currently leading a research team that's working on a rapid smell-based test called Sentinel to identify cases of COVID-19. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Dalton. That's my pleasure, Kim. Because COVID-19 is top of mind for most of us these days, can you tell our listeners,
and how smell affects our emotions and our memories. She's been called a smell ebriety, especially because of her work to identify the worst smell in the world, which we will talk about. How could we not? She's currently leading a research team that's working on a rapid smell-based test called Sentinel to identify cases of COVID-19. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Dalton. That's my pleasure, Kim. Because COVID-19 is top of mind for most of us these days, can you tell our listeners,|||以及嗅觉如何影响我们的情绪和记忆。她被称为嗅觉狂热者，特别是由于她致力于识别世界上最糟糕气味的工作，我们等下会聊到这个。我们怎么能不聊呢？她目前正领导一个研究团队，致力于开发一种名为“哨兵”（Sentinel）的基于快速嗅觉测试的方法，以识别 COVID-19 病例。非常感谢您今天能作客我们的节目，道尔顿博士。不用谢，金。由于 COVID-19 近期是大多数人最关心的问题，您能否告诉我们的听众，
do researchers know why COVID interferes with the sense of smell and is loss of smell a common side effect of other viruses? First of all, a loss of smell. following a virus has been known before, but it has never been as common or as prevalent as it is with the COVID-19 virus. And so we are experiencing a tremendous surge in people, the prevalence of people who are losing their sense of smell, even for a brief period of time. And what it's doing is making them aware of just how important this sensory system is. I've read reports that COVID can cause both anosmia, the loss of smell, or parosmia changes in smell. Can you talk a little bit about the differences between the two and describe what you and other researchers have found?
do researchers know why COVID interferes with the sense of smell and is loss of smell a common side effect of other viruses? First of all, a loss of smell. following a virus has been known before, but it has never been as common or as prevalent as it is with the COVID-19 virus. And so we are experiencing a tremendous surge in people, the prevalence of people who are losing their sense of smell, even for a brief period of time. And what it's doing is making them aware of just how important this sensory system is. I've read reports that COVID can cause both anosmia, the loss of smell, or parosmia changes in smell. Can you talk a little bit about the differences between the two and describe what you and other researchers have found?|||研究人员是否知道为什么新冠会干扰嗅觉？嗅觉丧失是其他病毒常见的副作用吗？首先，病毒感染后出现嗅觉丧失以前就已知晓，但它从未像新冠病毒那样普遍或盛行。因此，我们看到经历嗅觉丧失（哪怕是很短一段时间）的人数激增。而这让他们意识到这个感觉系统究竟有多么重要。我读过一些报道，称新冠既会导致完全性嗅觉丧失（anosmia），也会导致嗅觉减退或异常（parosmia）。您能简单谈谈这两者的区别，并描述一下您和其他研究人员的发现吗？
Yes. Well, certainly it seems that anosmia, which is the complete loss of ability to smell, is the most dramatic manifestation of a virus, including COVID. It seems like it's turning a light switch off. From one minute, you're tasting and smelling, and the next minute, that olfactory sense is completely gone. And, of course, that affects not only your ability to smell, but your appreciation of flavor. So if you're drinking or eating something, it's going to taste or have the flavor of something completely different
Yes. Well, certainly it seems that anosmia, which is the complete loss of ability to smell, is the most dramatic manifestation of a virus, including COVID. It seems like it's turning a light switch off. From one minute, you're tasting and smelling, and the next minute, that olfactory sense is completely gone. And, of course, that affects not only your ability to smell, but your appreciation of flavor. So if you're drinking or eating something, it's going to taste or have the flavor of something completely different|||可以。嗯，当然，anosmia（即完全丧失嗅觉能力）似乎是包括新冠在内的病毒最戏剧性的表现。这就像是关掉电灯开关一样。前一分钟你还在品尝和闻到气味，下一分钟那个嗅觉就完全消失了。当然，这不仅会影响你的嗅觉能力，还会影响你对风味的体验。所以如果你在喝或吃什么东西，一旦嗅觉消失，它尝起来就会完全变成另一种东西的味道。
once smell is gone. At that point, however, it turns out that people are not always aware, of changes in their sense of smell unless it is completely gone. And so studies that have actually measured people's ability to smell objectively, as opposed to ask for self-report, have found that there are many more people who have an alteration. So, for example, there is a condition called hyposmia, which is a decrease in your sensitivity, which most people may not be aware of unless they were tested.
once smell is gone. At that point, however, it turns out that people are not always aware, of changes in their sense of smell unless it is completely gone. And so studies that have actually measured people's ability to smell objectively, as opposed to ask for self-report, have found that there are many more people who have an alteration. So, for example, there is a condition called hyposmia, which is a decrease in your sensitivity, which most people may not be aware of unless they were tested.|||然而，就在那个时候，事实证明，除非嗅觉完全消失，否则人们并不总是能察觉到自己嗅觉的变化。因此，那些客观测量人们嗅觉能力（而不是要求自我报告）的研究发现，有更多的人其实发生了改变。例如，有一种叫做“嗅觉减退”（hyposmia）的状况，也就是你敏感度的下降，如果不是经过测试，大多数人可能根本不会察觉到。
But it turns out that a really high percentage of people that contract COVID do have either anosmia or hyposmia when tested. Parasmia, on the other hand, is a different condition. It's the ability to smell, but it's the distortion of what things smell like. So your favorite cup of coffee suddenly smells like gasoline or your chocolate energy bar smells a lot like your dog's purse. poop, which is really very disturbing. However, we think this is actually what happens potentially in the process of recovery of smell when you have lost your sense of smell and the odor system, the olfactory system, is regenerating. And there's still a lot to be learned about this condition. It's been very prevalent in COVID, unlike prior viral disorders.
But it turns out that a really high percentage of people that contract COVID do have either anosmia or hyposmia when tested. Parasmia, on the other hand, is a different condition. It's the ability to smell, but it's the distortion of what things smell like. So your favorite cup of coffee suddenly smells like gasoline or your chocolate energy bar smells a lot like your dog's purse. poop, which is really very disturbing. However, we think this is actually what happens potentially in the process of recovery of smell when you have lost your sense of smell and the odor system, the olfactory system, is regenerating. And there's still a lot to be learned about this condition. It's been very prevalent in COVID, unlike prior viral disorders.|||但事实证明，经测试，感染新冠的人群中有相当高的比例确实患有 anosmia（嗅觉丧失）或 hyposmia（嗅觉减退）。另一方面，parosmia（嗅觉异常）则是一种不同的状况。它能闻到气味，但对气味的感知发生了扭曲。所以你最喜欢的咖啡突然闻起来像汽油，或者你的巧克力能量棒闻起来很像你狗的便便，这真的非常令人不安。不过，我们认为这实际上可能是当你失去嗅觉而嗅觉系统正在再生时，嗅觉恢复过程中潜在发生的情况。关于这种状况，还有很多需要了解的地方。与以往的病毒性疾病不同，它在新冠肺炎中非常普遍。
And so we're really, unfortunately, having a great opportunity to study it and perhaps understand it in a way we never had the opportunity to do so before. Now, I mentioned in my introduction that smell is an underappreciated sense and that people don't realize how important it is until they lose it. How does the loss of smell or changes in their sense of smell affect people? What are the mental, physical, and emotional results of losing your sense of smell? It's really interesting because people are not aware until they lose it about how much it informs their ability to know where they are in time and space, their environment. It's sort of the backdrop of everywhere we go and everyone we interact with.
And so we're really, unfortunately, having a great opportunity to study it and perhaps understand it in a way we never had the opportunity to do so before. Now, I mentioned in my introduction that smell is an underappreciated sense and that people don't realize how important it is until they lose it. How does the loss of smell or changes in their sense of smell affect people? What are the mental, physical, and emotional results of losing your sense of smell? It's really interesting because people are not aware until they lose it about how much it informs their ability to know where they are in time and space, their environment. It's sort of the backdrop of everywhere we go and everyone we interact with.|||因此，不幸的是，我们确实得到了一个绝佳的机会来研究它，并以一种我们以前从未有过的方式来理解它。现在，我在介绍中提到，嗅觉是一种被低估的感官，直到失去它，人们才意识到它有多重要。嗅觉的丧失或嗅觉的变化是如何影响人们的？失去嗅觉会带来什么样的心理、身体和情感结果？这真的很有趣，因为人们在失去它之前并没有意识到它在多大程度上帮助他们了解自己在时空和环境中的位置。它就像是我们所到之处和与之交往的每个人的背景。
It's a piece of the fabric of our lives that we just don't appreciate until it's been cut away. So, for example, people talk about feeling disconnected. People talk about feeling disoriented or lost. They hug a loved one and they feel like there's an important piece of the emotional response that's missing. A recognition of who it is that they didn't even realize was encoded as part of their, their representation of that person until it was missing. On the Manel Center website, there's a section about how parents can talk to children
It's a piece of the fabric of our lives that we just don't appreciate until it's been cut away. So, for example, people talk about feeling disconnected. People talk about feeling disoriented or lost. They hug a loved one and they feel like there's an important piece of the emotional response that's missing. A recognition of who it is that they didn't even realize was encoded as part of their, their representation of that person until it was missing. On the Manel Center website, there's a section about how parents can talk to children|||它是我们生活结构的一部分，直到它被切除，我们才真正去感激它。例如，人们谈到感到脱节。人们谈到感到迷失方向或失落。他们拥抱爱人时，会觉得缺少了情感反应中至关重要的一部分。直到失去时，他们才意识到原来对那个人的某种认知和代表已经被编码在他们的记忆中。在莫内尔中心的网站上，有一个关于父母如何与孩子沟通的专栏，
about the loss of smell. I know children are not as susceptible to COVID as adults, but those who do get it, is the loss of smell as common among children as it is in adults? Quite honestly, Kim, we don't know yet. And that's something that we're trying to learn with our sentinel test,
about the loss of smell. I know children are not as susceptible to COVID as adults, but those who do get it, is the loss of smell as common among children as it is in adults? Quite honestly, Kim, we don't know yet. And that's something that we're trying to learn with our sentinel test,|||内容是关于嗅觉丧失的。我知道儿童不像成年人那样容易感染新冠，但对于确实感染的孩子来说，儿童中嗅觉丧失的情况像成年人那样普遍吗？老实说，金，我们还不知道。这也是我们试图通过我们的“哨兵”测试去了解的事情，
because as you mentioned in your introduction, we're developing a very easy-to-use rapid smell test that we think could be suitable for children. I worked on the National Institutes of Health Toolbox odor ID test a number of years ago, and the goal there was to be able to test children as young as three years old in order to be able to assess their ability to smell.
because as you mentioned in your introduction, we're developing a very easy-to-use rapid smell test that we think could be suitable for children. I worked on the National Institutes of Health Toolbox odor ID test a number of years ago, and the goal there was to be able to test children as young as three years old in order to be able to assess their ability to smell.|||因为正如你在介绍中提到的，我们正在开发一种非常易于使用的快速嗅觉测试，我们认为它可能适合儿童。多年前，我曾参与美国国立卫生研究院工具箱气味识别测试的工作，当时的目标是能够测试年仅三岁的儿童，以便评估他们的嗅觉能力。
And this was, irregardless of virus, just sort of understanding the natural ability to smell the same way you would test a child's hearing or their vision, because it is an important sensory system. And so we don't really know what the prevalence is among children, but we do know that children may experience their worlds very differently if they lose their sense of smell, and they may not have the language to communicate what that feels like.
And this was, irregardless of virus, just sort of understanding the natural ability to smell the same way you would test a child's hearing or their vision, because it is an important sensory system. And so we don't really know what the prevalence is among children, but we do know that children may experience their worlds very differently if they lose their sense of smell, and they may not have the language to communicate what that feels like.|||这与病毒无关，只是为了解自然的嗅觉能力，就像测试孩子的听觉或视觉一样，因为它是一个重要的感觉系统。因此，我们并不是很清楚它在儿童中的发病率，但我们确实知道，如果儿童失去嗅觉，他们体验世界的方式可能会大不相同，而且他们可能没有语言来表达那种感觉。
Probably prior to viral disorders and post-viral olfactory dysfunction, the most common way for children to lose their sense of smell of smell would be following a head injury, a sports-related head injury or something like that. And so that was really the only cases where we actually had a sense of prevalence. And there, it turned out that the sense of smell was actually pretty, how quickly it returned or whether you lost it, actually was pretty indicative of how serious the head injury was. Post-virally, we're really still learning. I'm intrigued by the idea you mentioned a little while ago,
Probably prior to viral disorders and post-viral olfactory dysfunction, the most common way for children to lose their sense of smell of smell would be following a head injury, a sports-related head injury or something like that. And so that was really the only cases where we actually had a sense of prevalence. And there, it turned out that the sense of smell was actually pretty, how quickly it returned or whether you lost it, actually was pretty indicative of how serious the head injury was. Post-virally, we're really still learning. I'm intrigued by the idea you mentioned a little while ago,|||可能在病毒性疾病和病毒感染后嗅觉功能障碍之前，儿童失去嗅觉最常见的原因是头部受伤，比如与运动相关的头部受伤之类的。所以这确实是我们真正掌握发病率的仅有案例。结果表明，嗅觉实际上非常……它恢复的速度有多快，或者你是否失去了它，其实很好地说明了头部受伤有多严重。对于病毒感染后的情况，我们确实还在摸索中。我对你刚才提到的一种观点很感兴趣，
of the fact that you can measure how acute people's sense of smell is and if it changes over time. I mean, we're all used to taking eye tests. We take hearing tests. You know, there are things that I think are sort of baselines that everybody agrees. The E is facing left or right. We know how many decibels that sound is. It's coming into our right ear. But how do you measure the degree of taste that someone is experiencing?
of the fact that you can measure how acute people's sense of smell is and if it changes over time. I mean, we're all used to taking eye tests. We take hearing tests. You know, there are things that I think are sort of baselines that everybody agrees. The E is facing left or right. We know how many decibels that sound is. It's coming into our right ear. But how do you measure the degree of taste that someone is experiencing?|||即你可以测量人们的嗅觉有多敏锐，以及它是否会随时间而改变。我的意思是，我们都习惯了做视力测试。我们做听力测试。你知道，有些事情我认为是每个人都同意的某种基准。视力表上的“E”字朝左还是朝右。我们知道那个声音是多少分贝。它正进入我们的右耳。但是，你如何衡量某人正在体验的味觉程度呢？
In the laboratory in a research setting, you would probably measure what their threshold is for detection, presenting them the same way you would decrease the size of the letters on an eye chart or you would decrease the decibels, you would decrease the concentration of a chemical and you would ask them at what point they could detect. And there are different ways to do that. That takes a lot of time. It's quite involved. It would be done, especially for clinical purposes, if someone came in and said, I lost my sense of smell and you would want to evaluate that. But in a rapid screening test, there are other ways to get at that information quickly. And then if you find a problem, you can refer someone for that more involved
In the laboratory in a research setting, you would probably measure what their threshold is for detection, presenting them the same way you would decrease the size of the letters on an eye chart or you would decrease the decibels, you would decrease the concentration of a chemical and you would ask them at what point they could detect. And there are different ways to do that. That takes a lot of time. It's quite involved. It would be done, especially for clinical purposes, if someone came in and said, I lost my sense of smell and you would want to evaluate that. But in a rapid screening test, there are other ways to get at that information quickly. And then if you find a problem, you can refer someone for that more involved|||在实验室的研究环境中，你可能会测量他们的检测阈值，采用的方法就像减小视力表上字母的大小或降低分贝一样，你会降低化学物质的浓度，并询问他们在哪个点能够检测到。有不同的方法可以做到这一点。这需要很多时间。过程相当复杂。这通常出于临床目的而进行，比如如果有人来诊所说“我失去了嗅觉”，你就会想要进行评估。但在快速筛查测试中，还有其他方法可以快速获取该信息。然后，如果你发现问题，你可以将患者转诊进行更深入的
kind of testing. But it basically follows the same sensory changes that you would use. It's a field called psychophysics that is used in vision and hearing as well. It's just done with odorants instead of letters or sounds. Most patient sense of smell does seem to come back, I understand, but for those who have long-lasting effects, is there hope or there treatments that you can use to help people regain their sense of smell? And can you train yourself to smell again? There is some hope. It turns out that at least with COVID, most people do recover their sense of smell. Sometimes even in a week or two following the initial other symptoms or their positive diagnosis. Some take up to two to three to three.
kind of testing. But it basically follows the same sensory changes that you would use. It's a field called psychophysics that is used in vision and hearing as well. It's just done with odorants instead of letters or sounds. Most patient sense of smell does seem to come back, I understand, but for those who have long-lasting effects, is there hope or there treatments that you can use to help people regain their sense of smell? And can you train yourself to smell again? There is some hope. It turns out that at least with COVID, most people do recover their sense of smell. Sometimes even in a week or two following the initial other symptoms or their positive diagnosis. Some take up to two to three to three.|||那种测试。但这基本上遵循了你所使用的相同的感官变化原理。这是一个被称为心理物理学的领域，它也适用于视觉和听觉。它只是用气味剂代替了字母或声音。据我了解，大多数患者的嗅觉似乎都会恢复，但对于那些有长期影响的人来说，有希望吗？或者有什么治疗方法可以用来帮助人们恢复嗅觉吗？你能通过训练让自己重新闻到气味吗？是有一些希望的。事实证明，至少对于新冠而言，大多数人确实恢复了嗅觉。有时甚至在最初的其他症状出现或确诊后的头一两周内就能恢复。有些人需要两到三个月。
three months and during that period of time, their ability to smell might fluctuate. They'll smell something and then it'll go away and then one day they'll have a good sense of smell the next day not. Unfortunately, it looks like about maybe 10% of people who have been diagnosed with COVID and who have lost their sense of smell, it persists for longer. Now, in other post-viral olfactory disorders, if you follow people out long enough, it looks like you can still recover even up to two to three years after you've lost it. You may not recover completely. You may not be back to where you started, but you might have enough of a functioning sense of smell to navigate your world and to enjoy food again. So we are trying to sort of jump
three months and during that period of time, their ability to smell might fluctuate. They'll smell something and then it'll go away and then one day they'll have a good sense of smell the next day not. Unfortunately, it looks like about maybe 10% of people who have been diagnosed with COVID and who have lost their sense of smell, it persists for longer. Now, in other post-viral olfactory disorders, if you follow people out long enough, it looks like you can still recover even up to two to three years after you've lost it. You may not recover completely. You may not be back to where you started, but you might have enough of a functioning sense of smell to navigate your world and to enjoy food again. So we are trying to sort of jump|||三个月，在此期间，他们的嗅觉可能会波动。他们会闻到某种气味，然后又消失了，然后有一天他们的嗅觉很好，第二天又不行了。不幸的是，看起来大约有 10% 诊断出新冠且失去嗅觉的人，这种症状会持续更长时间。现在，在其他病毒感染后的嗅觉障碍中，如果你对人们进行足够长时间的追踪随访，看起来即使在失去嗅觉两到三年后，你仍然可以恢复。你可能无法完全恢复。你可能无法回到最初的起点，但你可能拥有足够的嗅觉功能来在你的世界中穿行并再次享受食物。所以我们正试图跳过
start that process. And that's one thing that olfactory training is intended to be used for. that instead of avoiding smelling things because you can't smell, you actually stimulate your system with four or five different odorants that you smell religiously every day, a couple of times a day. Sometimes you think about what the odor smelled like when you could remember it. Sometimes you look at a picture. There's different ways to do it. But the idea is the more you stimulate the olfactory system, the more you might actually regrow or regenerate the capacity that you. you had before. So does that mean that there are cells that are lost that can grow back? Is that what's happening physically? It depends on the virus. Some viruses appear to actually affect the
start that process. And that's one thing that olfactory training is intended to be used for. that instead of avoiding smelling things because you can't smell, you actually stimulate your system with four or five different odorants that you smell religiously every day, a couple of times a day. Sometimes you think about what the odor smelled like when you could remember it. Sometimes you look at a picture. There's different ways to do it. But the idea is the more you stimulate the olfactory system, the more you might actually regrow or regenerate the capacity that you. you had before. So does that mean that there are cells that are lost that can grow back? Is that what's happening physically? It depends on the virus. Some viruses appear to actually affect the|||启动这个过程。这就是嗅觉训练的目的。也就是说，与其因为闻不到气味而避免去闻东西，不如用四五种不同的气味剂来刺激你的系统，你每天虔诚地闻它们几次。有时你会去回想当你还能记住时，这种气味是什么样子的。有时你看一张图片。有不同的方法可以做到这一点。但其理念是，你对嗅觉系统的刺激越多，你实际上就越有可能重新生长或再生你以前拥有的能力。那么这是否意味着丢失的细胞可以重新长出来？这就是生理上发生的事情吗？这取决于病毒。有些病毒似乎真的会影响
receptors themselves. It appears that in COVID, in a study that was done by Dr. Bob Data at Harvard, that what gets disrupted by the virus are the supporting cells, the ones that actually work to produce and feed the olfactory receptors. And so once that base gets disrupted, then you have olfactor receptors that turn over. Elfactory receptors have a short lifespan. They regenerate continuously throughout life. But if the architecture isn't there to help them regenerate, then you're going to have a loss. And so that's the current main hypothesis of how COVID is disrupting the olfactory system. Once the virus is no longer affecting those supporting cells, they may regenerate, and then the olfactory receptors can start regrowing their connections
receptors themselves. It appears that in COVID, in a study that was done by Dr. Bob Data at Harvard, that what gets disrupted by the virus are the supporting cells, the ones that actually work to produce and feed the olfactory receptors. And so once that base gets disrupted, then you have olfactor receptors that turn over. Elfactory receptors have a short lifespan. They regenerate continuously throughout life. But if the architecture isn't there to help them regenerate, then you're going to have a loss. And so that's the current main hypothesis of how COVID is disrupting the olfactory system. Once the virus is no longer affecting those supporting cells, they may regenerate, and then the olfactory receptors can start regrowing their connections|||受体本身。在新冠病毒中，哈佛大学鲍勃·达塔（Bob Datta）博士的一项研究表明，被病毒破坏的是支持细胞，即那些实际负责产生和滋养嗅觉受体的细胞。因此，一旦这个基础遭到破坏，你的嗅觉受体就会发生更替。嗅觉受体的寿命很短。它们在整个人生中不断再生。但如果没有相应的架构来帮助它们再生，你就会失去嗅觉。因此，这就是目前关于新冠如何破坏嗅觉系统的主流假说。一旦病毒不再影响这些支持细胞，它们可能会再生，然后嗅觉受体就可以开始重新生长它们的连接，
to be able to allow us to experience what is smell again. So you're working on an NIH-funded initiative to develop a rapid smell test to identify COVID cases. Can you talk about that? And why would a smell test be better than the test that we have right now? Well, we can't say that it's better than an actual diagnostic test, like a nasal swab or an antigen test or saliva test. But it certainly seems to be better than the symptom screening that people are doing or the temperature screening that people are doing in order to return to the workplace or go into a building or a restaurant.
to be able to allow us to experience what is smell again. So you're working on an NIH-funded initiative to develop a rapid smell test to identify COVID cases. Can you talk about that? And why would a smell test be better than the test that we have right now? Well, we can't say that it's better than an actual diagnostic test, like a nasal swab or an antigen test or saliva test. But it certainly seems to be better than the symptom screening that people are doing or the temperature screening that people are doing in order to return to the workplace or go into a building or a restaurant.|||从而使我们能够重新体验什么是嗅觉。因此，您正在参与一项由美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）资助的计划，旨在开发一种用于识别新冠病例的快速嗅觉测试。您能谈谈这个吗？为什么嗅觉测试会比我们现有的测试更好呢？嗯，我们不能说它比实际的诊断测试更好，比如鼻拭子、抗原测试或唾液测试。但它肯定比人们为了返回工作场所、进入大楼或餐馆而正在进行的症状筛查或体温筛查要好。
I mean, every restaurant I go to in Philadelphia takes my temperature before I go in. Yet we know from thousands and hundreds of thousands of instances that this is a very unlikely way to pick up a positive COVID test case. And so given that there have been studies done by this international group of researchers of which many people at Monell are apart, but worldwide, we know that the sense of smell, the loss of sense of smell is actually more predictive than a fever, especially. in the early stages of COVID infection, when you might not have a fever yet or you might not have any other symptoms, but you might be infectious. You might be capable of transmitting
I mean, every restaurant I go to in Philadelphia takes my temperature before I go in. Yet we know from thousands and hundreds of thousands of instances that this is a very unlikely way to pick up a positive COVID test case. And so given that there have been studies done by this international group of researchers of which many people at Monell are apart, but worldwide, we know that the sense of smell, the loss of sense of smell is actually more predictive than a fever, especially. in the early stages of COVID infection, when you might not have a fever yet or you might not have any other symptoms, but you might be infectious. You might be capable of transmitting|||我的意思是，我在费城去的每家餐馆在我进去之前都会量体温。然而，通过成千上万个例子，我们知道这是一种极不可能检测出新冠阳性病例的方法。鉴于这个国际研究小组（其中许多人来自莫内尔，但遍布全球）已经开展了研究，我们知道嗅觉的丧失实际上比发烧更具预测性，尤其是在新冠感染的早期阶段，那时你可能还没有发烧，或者你可能没有任何其他症状，但你可能已经具有传染性。你可能具备传播
the virus to someone else. And so for that reason, we think it has more value as a screening test. Now, of course, it can be paired with fever temperature screening and symptom screening as well. But we think it will be, in the long run, as a suite of assessments, a better way to identify people who may have COVID, but who are otherwise asymptomatic. What might this look like? I mean, we know what these swabs are, and we've seen the guns that they point at your head to take your temperature, but how will they test your smell? Well, what we have is a card. It's a single card about five by seven, and there are three patches on it. Each one of them is sort of a glue, but only one of them has an odor embedded in
the virus to someone else. And so for that reason, we think it has more value as a screening test. Now, of course, it can be paired with fever temperature screening and symptom screening as well. But we think it will be, in the long run, as a suite of assessments, a better way to identify people who may have COVID, but who are otherwise asymptomatic. What might this look like? I mean, we know what these swabs are, and we've seen the guns that they point at your head to take your temperature, but how will they test your smell? Well, what we have is a card. It's a single card about five by seven, and there are three patches on it. Each one of them is sort of a glue, but only one of them has an odor embedded in|||病毒给其他人的能力。因此，出于这个原因，我们认为它作为筛查测试具有更高的价值。当然，它也可以与发热体温筛查和症状筛查相结合。但从长远来看，我们认为作为一套评估方法，它将是识别可能患有新冠但无其他症状的人的更好方法。这会是什么样子呢？我的意思是，我们知道这些拭子是什么，我们也见过他们把枪对准你的头部来测量体温的测温枪，但他们将如何测试你的嗅觉呢？嗯，我们有的是一张卡片。这是一张大约五乘七大小的单张卡片，上面有三个小贴片。它们中的每一个都有点像胶水，但其中只有一张嵌入了气味，
the glue, and it's covered by a little plastic screen. that you lift up, so you don't have to scratch it. Many smell tests are scratch and sniff. And while they're very good in a controlled environment, the intensity of the odor depends on how you scratch it. You have to have something to scratch it with. And so we were thinking practically about somebody going into an office where there might be 400 people entering, you know, at 8.30 in the morning,
the glue, and it's covered by a little plastic screen. that you lift up, so you don't have to scratch it. Many smell tests are scratch and sniff. And while they're very good in a controlled environment, the intensity of the odor depends on how you scratch it. You have to have something to scratch it with. And so we were thinking practically about somebody going into an office where there might be 400 people entering, you know, at 8.30 in the morning,|||并且它被一个小塑料膜覆盖着，你可以把它掀起来，所以你不必去刮它。许多嗅觉测试都是“刮刮闻”（scratch and sniff）。虽然它们在受控环境中非常好，但气味的强度取决于你如何刮它。你必须有东西来刮它。因此，从实际出发，我们考虑到有人去办公室，早上 8 点 30 分可能会有 400 人进入，
something that could be done very quickly. So you lift the screen on each of these three patches. And first of all, you scan the QR code with a smartphone. And that brings you to a little survey on your phone. You lift the patches, you smell each one, and you tell us which one has the strongest odor. Because the glue has a little bit of odor. We're trying to work on that.
something that could be done very quickly. So you lift the screen on each of these three patches. And first of all, you scan the QR code with a smartphone. And that brings you to a little survey on your phone. You lift the patches, you smell each one, and you tell us which one has the strongest odor. Because the glue has a little bit of odor. We're trying to work on that.|||这个测试可以非常快地完成。所以你掀开这三个贴片上的塑料膜。首先，你用智能手机扫描二维码。这会带你进入手机上的一个小调查。你掀开贴片，闻一闻每一个，然后告诉我们哪一个的气味最强。因为胶水本身有一点气味。我们正在努力解决这个问题。
Then you tell us how strong it is. And that's another really important indicator of COVID, because you may not lose your sense of smell completely, but something that smell, let's say, on a zero to a hundred scale yesterday, as an 80, all of a sudden smells like a 20 to you. Something has changed, right? And so then the final question is, what does it smell like? And your smartphone shows you four pictures with labels,
Then you tell us how strong it is. And that's another really important indicator of COVID, because you may not lose your sense of smell completely, but something that smell, let's say, on a zero to a hundred scale yesterday, as an 80, all of a sudden smells like a 20 to you. Something has changed, right? And so then the final question is, what does it smell like? And your smartphone shows you four pictures with labels,|||然后你告诉我们它有多强。这是新冠的另一个非常重要的指标，因为你可能没有完全失去嗅觉，但如果昨天在零到一百的量表上评分为 80 的某种气味，突然对你来说闻起来像 20。有些东西改变了，对吧？然后最后一个问题是，它闻起来像什么？你的智能手机会向你展示四张带有标签的图片，
and you have to decide which one it is. So basically, we're trying to test all three different functions, of the way we use our sense of smell in one rapid test. And this can be done within two minutes for the first time you've used it and probably less than a minute on subsequent times. So the throughput is pretty rapid. And we're hopeful that people that are using it will find it to be equally as convenient.
and you have to decide which one it is. So basically, we're trying to test all three different functions, of the way we use our sense of smell in one rapid test. And this can be done within two minutes for the first time you've used it and probably less than a minute on subsequent times. So the throughput is pretty rapid. And we're hopeful that people that are using it will find it to be equally as convenient.|||你必须决定它是哪一个。所以基本上，我们试图在一个快速测试中测试我们使用嗅觉的三种不同功能。对于第一次使用的人来说，这可以在两分钟内完成，而在随后的使用中可能不到一分钟。所以吞吐量相当快。我们希望使用它的人会发现它同样方便。
There's been a lot written about dogs that can sniff out cancer and other diseases. And a couple of years ago, there was a spate of news stories about a woman in Scotland who could, could tell whether someone had Parkinson's disease by smelling their t-shirts. How much does science know at this point about the smell of particular diseases and how might that knowledge help in diagnosis and treatment? We think it's very important. Back before there were diagnostic tests for a lot of diseases, it was very common for physicians
There's been a lot written about dogs that can sniff out cancer and other diseases. And a couple of years ago, there was a spate of news stories about a woman in Scotland who could, could tell whether someone had Parkinson's disease by smelling their t-shirts. How much does science know at this point about the smell of particular diseases and how might that knowledge help in diagnosis and treatment? We think it's very important. Back before there were diagnostic tests for a lot of diseases, it was very common for physicians|||有很多关于狗能嗅出癌症和其他疾病的报道。几年前，有一连串的新闻报道说，苏格兰有一位女性可以通过闻 T 恤来判断某人是否患有帕金森病。目前科学界对特定疾病的气味了解多少？这些知识将如何有助于诊断和治疗？我们认为这非常重要。在许多疾病还没有诊断测试的过去，医生非常普遍的做法是
to come and smell a patient. And actually, there are so, certain things like certain ear infections in a child give off a particular odor. They're, you know, there are, of course, people who are in diabetic ketoacidosis have a very particular sort of fruity, appellee scent to them, which is an important way to distinguish them from someone who's otherwise intoxicated or inebriated, right? Because they won't smell like that. Right, right. So moving on to that, science.
to come and smell a patient. And actually, there are so, certain things like certain ear infections in a child give off a particular odor. They're, you know, there are, of course, people who are in diabetic ketoacidosis have a very particular sort of fruity, appellee scent to them, which is an important way to distinguish them from someone who's otherwise intoxicated or inebriated, right? Because they won't smell like that. Right, right. So moving on to that, science.|||来闻一闻患者的气味。实际上，有些事情……比如儿童的某些耳部感染会散发出一种特定的气味。你知道的，当然，患有糖尿病酮症酸中毒的人会有一种非常特殊的、像水果或苹果一样的气味，这是将他们与那些因其他原因醉酒或神志不清的人区分开来的重要方法，对吧？因为后者不会有这种气味。对的，对的。那么，言归正传，科学。
like my late colleague at the Monell Center, Dr. George Pretti, was using sense of smell and the volatiles that people emitted to diagnose other diseases. He was working with a group at the University of Pennsylvania at the Working Dog Center to diagnose early stage ovarian cancer, which, as you may know, is something that usually does not get diagnosed until late stages. It turns out that inflammation from infection does produce
like my late colleague at the Monell Center, Dr. George Pretti, was using sense of smell and the volatiles that people emitted to diagnose other diseases. He was working with a group at the University of Pennsylvania at the Working Dog Center to diagnose early stage ovarian cancer, which, as you may know, is something that usually does not get diagnosed until late stages. It turns out that inflammation from infection does produce|||比如我在莫内尔中心的已故同事乔治·普雷蒂（George Pretti）博士，就曾利用嗅觉和人们散发出的挥发性物质来诊断其他疾病。他曾与宾夕法尼亚大学工作犬中心的一个小组合作，诊断早期卵巢癌，正如你可能知道的那样，这种疾病通常直到晚期才被诊断出来。事实证明，感染引起的炎症确实会产生
does produce an odor in our bodies that anyone, even naive individuals, can discriminate. The question is, can you now get more specific? What is the nature of the infection? Is it viral? Is it bacterial? And one of my colleagues at the Monell Center, Bruce Kimball, just recently got a foundation grant to actually study that. So there's a lot of work going on in the diagnostic area of using smell, or at least using the chemical emissions from our bodies under different disease states.
does produce an odor in our bodies that anyone, even naive individuals, can discriminate. The question is, can you now get more specific? What is the nature of the infection? Is it viral? Is it bacterial? And one of my colleagues at the Monell Center, Bruce Kimball, just recently got a foundation grant to actually study that. So there's a lot of work going on in the diagnostic area of using smell, or at least using the chemical emissions from our bodies under different disease states.|||确实会在我们体内产生一种气味，任何人，甚至是缺乏经验的人都能分辨出来。问题是，你现在能更具体一点吗？感染的性质是什么？是病毒性的？还是细菌性的？我在莫内尔中心的一位同事布鲁斯·金博尔（Bruce Kimball）最近刚刚获得了一项基金资助来专门研究这一点。因此，在利用嗅觉（或至少利用不同疾病状态下我们身体释放的化学物质）进行诊断的领域，有很多工作正在进行。
Now, right now it's being done with dogs, but the hope is to use the dogs to be able to isolate what are the actual chemical signals and then build like an electronic nose or a sensor that can be used so that you don't have to bring a dog into an examining room and have, you know, during your physical exam and have him sniff different parts of your body. But quite honestly, if that's going to tell me something about my health, I'm all for it. That's okay, yeah. It's okay. You know, it kind of works both ways.
Now, right now it's being done with dogs, but the hope is to use the dogs to be able to isolate what are the actual chemical signals and then build like an electronic nose or a sensor that can be used so that you don't have to bring a dog into an examining room and have, you know, during your physical exam and have him sniff different parts of your body. But quite honestly, if that's going to tell me something about my health, I'm all for it. That's okay, yeah. It's okay. You know, it kind of works both ways.|||现在这项工作是通过狗来完成的，但希望能够利用狗来分离出实际的化学信号，然后构建类似于电子鼻或传感器的设备，这样你就不必把狗带进检查室，在体检时让它闻你身体的不同部位。但老实说，如果这能告诉我一些关于我健康的信息，我完全赞成。没关系，是的。没关系。你知道，这在某种程度上是双向的。
I had a vet a couple of years ago who wanted to decide whether my dog needed oral surgery and smelled her mouth. That was an important diagnostic tool for her. She was not trained in the U.S., but, you know, she was right. The dog needed oral surgery. Exactly, exactly. So, yes, that's a really, really developing area of research. and I think it holds a tremendous promise, and it's really one of the pillars of the Monell Center's strategic plan
I had a vet a couple of years ago who wanted to decide whether my dog needed oral surgery and smelled her mouth. That was an important diagnostic tool for her. She was not trained in the U.S., but, you know, she was right. The dog needed oral surgery. Exactly, exactly. So, yes, that's a really, really developing area of research. and I think it holds a tremendous promise, and it's really one of the pillars of the Monell Center's strategic plan|||几年前我有一位兽医，他想决定我的狗是否需要进行口腔手术，于是闻了闻它的嘴。对她来说，那是一个重要的诊断工具。她不是在美国受训的，但你知道，她是对的。那只狗确实需要口腔手术。确实，确实。所以，是的，这是一个非常、非常正在发展的研究领域，我认为它有着巨大的前景，而且它确实是莫内尔中心战略计划的支柱之一，
is to build on that. Let's talk about Spell a little more generally. How well do scientists understand how our olfactory system works compared with, say, our visual or auditory systems? What are the big questions that are unanswered? Well, we learned a lot going back around 15, 18 years ago, when the smell receptor, the ability to smell, the receptor was actually cloned and identified.
is to build on that. Let's talk about Spell a little more generally. How well do scientists understand how our olfactory system works compared with, say, our visual or auditory systems? What are the big questions that are unanswered? Well, we learned a lot going back around 15, 18 years ago, when the smell receptor, the ability to smell, the receptor was actually cloned and identified.|||旨在在此基础上继续发展。让我们更广泛地谈谈气味。与我们的视觉或听觉系统相比，科学家对我们的嗅觉系统是如何工作的了解程度如何？有哪些尚未解答的重大问题？嗯，回溯到大约 15、18 年前，我们学到了很多东西，当时嗅觉受体——即嗅觉能力——该受体被成功克隆并鉴定出来。
I can say that the sense of smell is the last sensory system to give up its secrets to science. It was very elusive for very long period of time. And some of that was the difficulty in actually using scent to test. I mean, it's always been something of a niche science, which was partly what attracted me to it to begin with, is that there were so many unanswered questions. that I found myself not almost knowing which way to turn,
I can say that the sense of smell is the last sensory system to give up its secrets to science. It was very elusive for very long period of time. And some of that was the difficulty in actually using scent to test. I mean, is always been something of a niche science, which was partly what attracted me to it in the first place, is that there were so many unanswered questions. that I found myself not almost knowing which way to turn,|||我可以这么说，嗅觉是最后一个向科学放弃其秘密的感觉系统。在很长一段时间里，它都非常难以捉摸。部分原因在于实际使用气味进行测试的难度。我的意思是，这一直是一门小众科学，这也是最初吸引我加入的部分原因，因为有太多未解之谜，以至于我发现自己几乎不知道该往哪个方向走，
which was a good thing for a young scientist 28 years ago. But now what really is the major outstanding questions is how do all these receptors work together and tell our brain what we're smelling? We know that we can discriminate probably hundreds of thousands of different sense, and we do so with about 400 different types of receptors that combine in different ways to send a signal to our brain that tells us we're smelling
which was a good thing for a young scientist 28 years ago. But now what really is the major outstanding questions is how do all these receptors work together and tell our brain what we're smelling? We know that we can discriminate probably hundreds of thousands of different sense, and we do so with about 400 different types of receptors that combine in different ways to send a signal to our brain that tells us we're smelling|||对于 28 年前的年轻科学家来说，这是一件好事。但现在真正主要的未解问题是：所有这些受体是如何协同工作并告诉我们的脑我们在闻什么的？我们知道我们可以分辨出大概数十万种不同的气味，我们是通过大约 400 种不同类型的受体做到这一点的，这些受体以不同的方式组合，向我们的大脑发送信号，告诉我们我们正在闻
this blend of coffee versus that blend of coffee. I mean, really, fine-grained discriminations. We still don't understand. The visual world and the auditory world work in two or three dimensions. Smell might work in many more dimensions than that, and we're still trying to figure out. So, for example, at this point in time, it's still unknown. If you take a chemical structure that is novel, how will it smell? In the same way that you could look at something on the hue or saturation, you know, the
this blend of coffee versus that blend of coffee. I mean, really, fine-grained discriminations. We still don't understand. The visual world and the auditory world work in two or three dimensions. Smell might work in many more dimensions than that, and we're still trying to figure out. So, for example, at this point in time, it's still unknown. If you take a chemical structure that is novel, how will it smell? In the same way that you could look at something on the hue or saturation, you know, the|||这种咖啡混合物还是那种咖啡混合物。我的意思是，真的，是非常精细的分辨。我们仍然不理解。视觉世界和听觉世界在二维或三维中工作。嗅觉的工作维度可能比这多得多，我们仍在努力弄清楚。例如，在目前这个时间点，仍然是个未知数。如果你拿到一种新颖的化学结构，它闻起来会是什么样？就像你可以查看色调或饱和度上的某些东西，你知道的，
color wheel and predict what it will look like to someone who has normal color vision. So we're really at the beginning of that. And a lot of my colleagues are really working very hard on that, but it is a very complex system. It's much more complex than vision or hearing. And so it's moving more slowly, but it is moving. I mean, the ultimate goal, of course, is to be able to digitize smell so that we can transmit a smell over our computers the same way we could. But we have to know how to create that spell.
color wheel and predict what it will look like to someone who has normal color vision. So we're really at the beginning of that. And a lot of my colleagues are really working very hard on that, but it is a very complex system. It's much more complex than vision or hearing. And so it's moving more slowly, but it is moving. I mean, the ultimate goal, of course, is to be able to digitize smell so that we can transmit a smell over our computers the same way we could. But we have to know how to create that spell.|||色轮，并预测色觉正常的人看到它会是什么样子。所以我们真的才刚刚开始。我的很多同事确实在为此付出巨大努力，但这是一个非常复杂的系统。它比视觉或听觉复杂得多。因此它的进展较慢，但它确实在前进。我的意思是，最终目标当然是能够将气味数字化，以便我们能够像传输其他东西一样通过电脑传输气味。但我们必须知道如何创造那种气味。
What are the components other than just putting a bunch of different molecules in a box next to your nose and trying to blend them? You know, are there more sophisticated ways of actually digital? digitizing smell the same way we can do with hearing with noises and also visual stimuli. I recently saw a report about a 3D printer that was making meat, and I would imagine that smell would be really important that if the meat doesn't smell like meat and if you cook it and it doesn't smell it right, then you're not going to eat, you know, printed meat.
What are the components other than just putting a bunch of different molecules in a box next to your nose and trying to blend them? You know, are there more sophisticated ways of actually digital? digitizing smell the same way we can do with hearing with noises and also visual stimuli. I recently saw a report about a 3D printer that was making meat, and I would imagine that smell would be really important that if the meat doesn't smell like meat and if you cook it and it doesn't smell it right, then you're not going to eat, you know, printed meat.|||除了把一堆不同的分子放进你鼻子旁边的盒子里并试图混合它们之外，还有哪些成分？你知道的，有没有更复杂的方法来真正数字化？就像我们可以对听觉、噪音以及视觉刺激进行数字化那样，对嗅觉进行数字化。我最近看到一篇关于 3D 打印肉类的报道，我想象如果肉闻起来不像肉，如果你烹饪它时气味不对，那么你就不会去吃那种打印出来的肉，对吧。
Exactly, yes. Yeah, I mean, it's the same thing that happens to someone who loses their sense of smell, right? All of a sudden, food becomes unappetizing. And that either leads them to stop eating because nothing works, nothing is pleasurable, and they lose weight, or the other side of the coin, which is where they continue eating because they're looking for that experience that they can't have. So it goes in both directions. So read that some people experience a loss of smell after they use a zinc nasal spray, and yet zinc seems to be really connected to the sense of taste. There's research showing that people with a taste disorder may see some improvement if they take zinc orally.
Exactly, yes. Yeah, I mean, it's the same thing that happens to someone who loses their sense of smell, right? All of a sudden, food becomes unappetizing. And that either leads them to stop eating because nothing works, nothing is pleasurable, and they lose weight, or the other side of the coin, which is where they continue eating because they're looking for that experience that they can't have. So it goes in both directions. So read that some people experience a loss of smell after they use a zinc nasal spray, and yet zinc seems to be really connected to the sense of taste. There's research showing that people with a taste disorder may see some improvement if they take zinc orally.|||完全正确，是的。是的，我的意思是，这与失去嗅觉的人身上发生的事情是一样的，对吧？突然之间，食物变得毫无食欲。这要么导致他们停止进食，因为什么都不起作用，什么都无法带来快乐，从而导致他们体重减轻；要么就是硬币的另一面，他们继续进食，因为他们在寻找那种他们无法获得的体验。所以它向两个方向发展。所以有报道称，一些人在使用锌鼻喷雾剂后出现了嗅觉丧失，然而锌似乎与味觉有着真正的联系。有研究表明，口服锌可能会让味觉障碍患者看到一些改善。
So how can zinc be bad for smell but good for taste since the two are very intricately connected? Right. Well, they are separate sensory systems in the periphery. You know, the taste buds and the taste receptors and the oral cavity and of which they are, all over our body, but for the purpose of food, we'll talk about the oral cavity, are peripherally distinct, but they do combine in the brain because flavor is the quintessential combination of taste and smell, a little bit of texture as well. Different chemicals are going to have different effects on different types of receptors, and zinc has been touted as a cure for smell loss, And it's also been implicated as something that causes people to at least transiently have a loss of smell.
So how can zinc be bad for smell but good for taste since the two are very intricately connected? Right. Well, they are separate sensory systems in the periphery. You know, the taste buds and the taste receptors and the oral cavity and of which they are, all over our body, but for the purpose of food, we'll talk about the oral cavity, are peripherally distinct, but they do combine in the brain because flavor is the quintessential combination of taste and smell, a little bit of texture as well. Different chemicals are going to have different effects on different types of receptors, and zinc has been touted as a cure for smell loss, And it's also been implicated as something that causes people to at least transiently have a loss of smell.|||既然这两者有着千丝万缕的联系，为什么锌对嗅觉有害，对味觉却有益呢？对。嗯，它们在外周是独立的感觉系统。你知道，味蕾、口腔中的味觉受体（它们遍布我们的全身，但为了食物的目的，我们只谈口腔），它们在外周是截然不同的，但它们在脑中确实结合在了一起，因为风味是味觉和嗅觉（以及一点点质感）的完美结合。不同的化学物质会对不同类型的受体产生不同的影响，锌曾被吹捧为治疗嗅觉丧失的良药，它也曾被牵连为导致人们至少短暂失去嗅觉的原因。
And so it's currently not recommended as a treatment for smell loss. In other words, inhaling zinc, a sulfate in the nasal spray. But it is something that people have used. It doesn't seem to be very effective and in some cases may actually cause the opposite effect. Of course, many people who were using it were also doing so because they thought it was going to ward off a virus or a cold. And the question remains, without a clear controlled study, would they have lost their sense of smell transiently anyway and attributed it to the zinc? So that's an open question. You've also done research in how smell is intertwined with memory.
And so it's currently not recommended as a treatment for smell loss. In other words, inhaling zinc, a sulfate in the nasal spray. But it is something that people have used. It doesn't seem to be very effective and in some cases may actually cause the opposite effect. Of course, many people who were using it were also doing so because they thought it was going to ward off a virus or a cold. And the question remains, without a clear controlled study, would they have lost their sense of smell transiently anyway and attributed it to the zinc? So that's open question. You've also done research in how smell is intertwined with memory.|||因此，目前不建议将其作为治疗嗅觉丧失的方法。换句话说，在鼻喷雾剂中吸入硫酸锌。但这确实是人们曾经使用过的方法。它似乎并不是很有效，在某些情况下甚至可能会产生相反的效果。当然，许多使用它的人也是因为他们认为这可以抵御病毒或感冒。问题依然存在，如果没有明确的对照研究，他们无论如何都会短暂失去嗅觉，并将其归咎于锌吗？所以这是一个悬而未决的问题。您还研究了嗅觉是如何与记忆交织在一起的。
And a lot of people, I think, have a intuitive sense of this. we know that certain smells will bring back vivid images of a particular time or place. Why are smell and memory so connected? Well, we think partly because of their anatomical proximity in the brain, that smell is actually part of the limbic system, which is our emotional system, that allows us to experience pleasure, fear, sadness, etc. And also part of the hippocampus, which is where memories, especially emotional memories, are stored. When we smell something, we often don't identify what we're smelling immediately,
And a lot of people, I think, have a intuitive sense of this. we know that certain smells will bring back vivid images of a particular time or place. Why are smell and memory so connected? Well, we think partly because of their anatomical proximity in the brain, that smell is actually part of the limbic system, which is our emotional system, that allows us to experience pleasure, fear, sadness, etc. And also part of the hippocampus, which is where memories, especially emotional memories, are stored. When we smell something, we often don't identify what we're smelling immediately,|||我想很多人对此都有直觉。我们知道某些气味会唤起特定时间或地点的生动画面。为什么嗅觉和记忆联系得如此紧密？嗯，我们认为部分原因是因为它们在大脑中的解剖学邻近性，嗅觉实际上是边缘系统的一部分，边缘系统是我们的情绪系统，使我们能够体验快乐、恐惧、悲伤等。它也是海马体的一部分，海马体是记忆（尤其是情感记忆）存储的地方。当我们闻到某种气味时，我们通常不会立即认出我们闻到的是什么，
but what we have is an association between that scent and a person, a place, an experience, a setting. So it's almost the cue that brings us back to that memory in a way that other stimuli may do so, but not at such an emotional level. A colleague of mine, studied this some years ago as well and showed that even though smells weren't better at recalling a memory, when people recall the memory that was associated with smell, they described it in much more emotional terms and probably felt much more emotional at the same time. And so we think that the interconnections in the cortex are what is responsible for that immediate sense of a flood of emotion or a flood of a memory when we smell something, you know, a perfume that our grandmother wore or the scent of a former boyfriend
but what we have is an association between that scent and a person, a place, an experience, a setting. So it's almost the cue that brings us back to that memory in a way that other stimuli may do so, but not at such an emotional level. A colleague of mine, studied this some years ago as well and showed that even though smells weren't better at recalling a memory, when people recall the memory that was associated with smell, they described it in much more emotional terms and probably felt much more emotional at the same time. And so we think that the interconnections in the cortex are what is responsible for that immediate sense of a flood of emotion or a flood of a memory when we smell something, you know, a perfume that our grandmother wore or the scent of a former boyfriend|||但我们拥有的是该气味与某个人、某个地方、某种经历、某种背景之间的联系。所以它几乎是一个线索，以其他刺激也能做到、但达不到如此强烈情感水平的方式，将我们带回那个记忆。我的一个同事几年前也研究过这一点，并表明尽管气味在回忆记忆方面并不更出色，但当人们回忆起与气味相关的记忆时，他们用更具情感色彩的词汇来描述它，并且可能同时感到更多情绪。因此，我们认为皮层中的相互连接正是导致我们在闻到某种气味时产生那种立即涌现的情感或记忆的洪流的原因，你知道的，比如我们祖母用过的香水，或者前男友的气味，
or, you know, the chalk smell of being in first grade in school when they still use chalkboards. Before COVID came along, one of the things that you were perhaps best known for was some research you did to determine the world's worst smell, an odor that virtually everyone would find repulsive. How did you do that? And of course, the kicker is what is the world's worst smell? Well, we had a lot of fun with that, Kim, actually. It was something that we were interested in from a scientific perspective because unlike taste, smell does not appear to be hardwired,
or, you know, the chalk smell of being in first grade in school when they still use chalkboards. Before COVID came along, one of the things that you were perhaps best known for was some research you did to determine the world's worst smell, an odor that virtually everyone would find repulsive. How did you do that? And of course, the kicker is what is the world's worst smell? Well, we had a lot of fun with that, Kim, actually. It was something that we were interested in from a scientific perspective because unlike taste, smell does not appear to be hardwired,|||或者，你知道的，一年级时学校里还在用黑板时的粉笔味。在新冠到来之前，你最著名的事迹之一可能是你为了确定世界上最糟糕的气味——几乎每个人都会觉得厌恶的气味——而做的一些研究。你是怎么做到的？当然，最让人好奇的是世界上最糟糕的气味究竟是什么？嗯，金，我们在那上面其实玩得很开心。从科学的角度来看，这是我们感兴趣的事情，因为与味觉不同，嗅觉似乎不是硬编码的，
our versions or preferences. Babies, you know, human babies, mice babies, all mammalian babies, will reject bitter tasting substances at birth, and they will avidly lick their lips to get something sweet. We don't have any real evidence that there are hardwired in native versions or preferences for smell, and so we wondered if there were universal maloders, what would they be?
our versions or preferences. Babies, you know, human babies, mice babies, all mammalian babies, will reject bitter tasting substances at birth, and they will avidly lick their lips to get something sweet. We don't have any real evidence that there are hardwired in native versions or preferences for smell, and so we wondered if there were universal maloders, what would they be?|||我们的厌恶或偏好。你知道的，人类婴儿、小老鼠婴儿、所有哺乳动物的婴儿在出生时都会拒绝味道苦的物质，并且会贪婪地舔嘴唇以获取甜的东西。我们没有任何确凿的证据表明嗅觉存在硬编码的天生厌恶或偏好，所以我们想知道如果存在普遍的恶臭，它们会是什么？
So we looked at biological odors of biological origin, assuming that everyone would have had experience with that at some point in time. We know, for example, that there are certain kinds of odors associated with foods that are highly preferred in some cultures and repulsed in others. I mean, let's take durian fruit, for example, where the smell of it is, yes. The smell of it is just, you know, to most people in Western cultures, really unpleasant. But if you grew up with that, and quite honestly, it really doesn't smell that same way once it's in your mouth. But you have to overcome that avoidance. So we looked at things like the smell of human waste,
So we looked at biological odors of biological origin, assuming that everyone would have had experience with that at some point in time. We know, for example, that there are certain kinds of odors associated with foods that are highly preferred in some cultures and repulsed in others. I mean, let's take durian fruit, for example, where the smell of it is, yes. The smell of it is just, you know, to most people in Western cultures, really unpleasant. But if you grew up with that, and quite honestly, it really doesn't smell that same way once it's in your mouth. But you have to overcome that avoidance. So we looked at things like the smell of human waste,|||因此，我们研究了生物来源的生物气味，假设每个人在某个时间点都曾体验过这些气味。例如，我们知道某些与食物相关的气味在某些文化中大受欢迎，而在其他文化中则令人反感。我的意思是，以榴莲为例，它的气味，是的。它的气味对西方文化的绝大多数人来说，真的很不愉快。但如果你是在那种环境下长大的，而且说实话，一旦它进入你的嘴里，它的味道真的就不一样了。但你必须克服那种回避心理。所以我们研究了诸如人类排泄物气味之类的事情，
the smell of decomposing flesh, burning organic matter. I collected hair from my hairdresser and burned that and we captured the odors into a matrix. And so we tested a lot of people. And what we were most interested in was people from different cultural backgrounds. And so I had some opportunity,
the smell of decomposing flesh, burning organic matter. I collected hair from my hairdresser and burned that and we captured the odors into a matrix. And so we tested a lot of people. And what we were most interested in was people from different cultural backgrounds. And so I had some opportunity,|||腐烂肉类的气味，燃烧有机物的气味。我从我的理发师那里收集了头发并将其烧掉，我们将这些气味捕获到一个矩阵中。因此我们测试了很多人。我们最感兴趣的是来自不同文化背景的人。所以我有一些机会，
I was actually working on summer programs in South Africa at the time. And so I took some of my odorants with me down to South Africa and tested people there, both white South Africans and black South Africans to see if there were differences, you know, culturally. We ended up finding a mixture of sense that comprised both organic decomposition, basically sulfur compounds and a little bit of human waste because that's a bit of human waste. because that's a danger signal to most people. I mean, maybe not the smell of your own bathroom, but when you smell unfamiliar human waste,
I was actually working on summer programs in South Africa at the time. And so I took some of my odorants with me down to South Africa and tested people there, both white South Africans and black South Africans to see if there were differences, you know, culturally. We ended up finding a mixture of sense that comprised both organic decomposition, basically sulfur compounds and a little bit of human waste because that's a bit of human waste. because that's a danger signal to most people. I mean, maybe not the smell of your own bathroom, but when you smell unfamiliar human waste,|||我当时实际上正在南非参与夏季项目。所以我带着我的一些气味剂去了南非，并在那里测试了当地人，包括南非白人和南非黑人，看看是否存在文化上的差异。我们最终发现了一种气味混合物，它既包含有机分解物（主要是硫化合物），又包含一点人类排泄物，因为那是人类排泄物的一部分。因为对大多数人来说那是危险信号。我的意思是，也许不是你自己的浴室的味道，但当你闻到不熟悉的人类排泄物时，
you really, in most cultures, and this was true, especially in places where there wasn't good sanitation, and I've worked in India on some of these kinds of odors as well as in South Africa, it can be a vector for disease. Now, the odor itself has no health impact, but it is a proxy.
you really, in most cultures, and this was true, especially in places where there wasn't good sanitation, and I've worked in India on some of these kinds of odors as well as in South Africa, it can be a vector for disease. Now, the odor itself has no health impact, but it is a proxy.|||在大多数文化中，确实如此，尤其是在卫生条件不好的地方，我在印度和南非都研究过这类气味，它可能成为疾病的媒介。现在，气味本身对健康没有影响，但它是一个代理指标。
and it's a warning that there's something there that can be dangerous for you. And so when we mix those together, we came up with something that we called stench soup. And it really did revolt everyone who smelled it. Is it available commercially? I mean, if you wanted to use it on somebody you don't particularly like. I am not going here. If somebody wants to reach out to me, that's different. But yes, no, we are not commercially providing that to anyone at this point in time.
and it's a warning that there's something there that can be dangerous for you. And so when we mix those together, we came up with something that we called stench soup. And it really did revolt everyone who smelled it. Is it available commercially? I mean, if you wanted to use it on somebody you don't particularly like. I am not going here. If somebody wants to reach out to me, that's different. But yes, no, we are not commercially providing that to anyone at this point in time.|||它是一个警告，表明那里有对你可能危险的东西。因此，当我们把这些混合在一起时，我们想出了一种我们称之为“恶臭汤”的东西。它确实让所有闻到它的人感到反胃。它在商业上买得到吗？我的意思是，如果你想把它用在你不太喜欢的人身上。我不会回答这个。如果有人想联系我，那是另一回事。但是，是的，不，我们目前没有向任何人商业化提供该产品。
But we were interested to at least see that, and you know, I did not have the opportunity to test this on a two-year-old child or a toddler, who we know is sometimes not at all repulsed by the smell of their own diaper or even their brother's diaper, right? So at what point in development does this actually occur? And that's something that, you know, we're still very interested in. It looks like there is a developmental trajectory. The president and director of Monell many years ago, the former director, actually really looked at this. But it turned out to be that around age eight, children started to mimic their parents' preferences and aversion. So there's definitely a learning process that goes on. Well, Dr. Dalton, this has been absolutely amazing.
但我们很高兴至少能看到这一点，你知道，我没有机会在一个两岁的小孩或幼儿身上测试这一点，我们知道他们有时对自己的尿布甚至他们兄弟的尿布的气味一点也不排斥，对吧？那么这究竟发生在发展的哪个阶段呢？这也是我们仍然非常感兴趣的事情。看起来确实存在一个发展的轨迹。莫内尔的主任兼总监多年前，也就是前总监，实际上真的研究过这个问题。但结果表明，在大约八岁左右，孩子们开始模仿父母的喜好和厌恶。所以这绝对是一个学习的过程。嗯，道尔顿博士，这真的太棒了。
I've really enjoyed talking with you. I appreciate your taking the time. It's a pleasure. Thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or an Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts, and please leave us a review.
我非常高兴能与您交谈。感谢您抽出时间。这是我的荣幸。非常感谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》的往期节目，请给我们留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org, that's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，您可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是 speakingofpsychology@apa.org，也就是 speakingofpsychology（全部连在一起）@apa.org。《心理学对话》由李·维纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condiion）。谢谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。